[Applause]
all right y'all we are back and our next
guest make quite The Talented pairing
she is a gifted actress and singer who
you've seen in shows like Victorious and
MTV's eye candy and films including a
perfect pairing and the tutor he is an
acclaimed songwriter producer and
pianist I actually worked with him um on
a couple of my songs on stronger album
he's also The Man Behind huge hits from
Adonna John ledge and Beyonce so many
people now performing a cover of
Fergie's Big Girls Don't Cry from his
forthcoming album piano Diaries volume
one give it up for Toby Gad and Victoria
[Applause]
Justice your skin
lingers on me
now probably on your fly back to your
[Music]
home I need some shelter my home
protction
baby
to be with myself and
[Music]
centerity I hope you know I hope you
know that this is do you it's
personal myself and I we got some
straight and I'm going to miss you like
a child misses the blanket
I got to get move on with my life it's
time to be a big girl
now Big Girls Don't
[Music]
Cry don't cry don't cry don't
cry the path that I'm walking I must go
alone yeah I must take the baby baby
step still I'm
full
full the fairy tales don't always have a
happy ending do
they die for see
thee if I
stay I hope you know I hope you
know that this is nothing to do with you
it's
personal myself and I we got some St and
out to
[Music]
doank it's time to be a girl
now big girls don't cry like a little
school in the school yard we'll play
Jackson
no and I'll be your best friend and you
be my
Valentine yes you can hold my hand if
you want
to I want to hold yours
tool we'll be Playmates and lovers and
share secet
world I hope you know I hope you know
that this is nothing to do with you it's
personal myself
and we got some straight out to do and
I'm going to miss you like a child blank
but i' got to get a move with my life
it's time to be a big girl
now and Big Girls Don't
[Music]
Cry time for Victoria Justice and Toby
g' Pi volume one featur some of Toby's
greatest songs reimagined Look
[Music]
[Applause]
for thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home